-Performing "Shy Away" from
their new album "Scaled and Icy"
here is Twenty One Pilots.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ When I get home ♪
♪ You better not be there,
we're placing bets you won't ♪
♪ Shed your modesty ♪
♪ And the only thing to leave
behind is your own skin ♪
♪ On the floor ♪
♪ Don't you shy away ♪
♪ Manifest a ceiling
when you shy away ♪
♪ Searching for that feeling ♪
♪ Just like an "I love you" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ That isn't words ♪
-♪ Like a song he wrote,
that's never heard ♪
♪ Don't you ♪
-♪ Shh ♪
♪♪
-♪ When you get home ♪
♪ You barely recognize the
pictures they put in a frame ♪
♪ 'Cause you shed your modesty ♪
♪ Don't circle the track ♪
♪ Take what you have ♪
♪ And leave your skin
on the floor ♪
♪ Don't you shy away ♪
♪ Manifest a ceiling
when you shy away ♪
♪ Searching for that feeling ♪
♪ Just like an "I love you" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ That isn't words ♪
-♪ Like a song he wrote,
that's never heard ♪
♪ When I get home ♪
♪ Boy, you better not be there,
you're long gone ♪
♪ Shed your modesty ♪
♪ Don't circle the track ♪
♪ Just break the cycle in half ♪
♪ And leave your skin
on the floor ♪
♪ Don't you shy away ♪
♪ Shy away ♪
♪ Searching for that feeling ♪
♪ Just like an "I love you" ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
-♪ That isn't words ♪
-♪ Like a song he wrote ♪
♪ That's never heard ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh-oh ♪
-♪ "I love you" ♪
♪ There isn't words ♪
♪ Like a song he wrote ♪
♪ That's never heard ♪
♪ Don't you shy away ♪
♪♪